[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALICE BARTLETT: I'm Alice.
I'm a principal engineer
at the "Financial Times."
I also founded Tampon Club.
And this is "How I Code."
So I code in the
FT building, which
is this big, brown office,
a massive cube on the River
Thames.
The office is full of mice.
They're fine, but they
will eat your cereal.
My desk is a horrible mess.
It's got paper all
over it, and then
Post-it notes of
things that I think
are really important
stuck to the monitor.
I sit with my team,
who I really like.
And we've got these
origami cranes everywhere
because the team is
called the Origami Team.
One of the things that I
think is really important
is writing good commit messages.
As developers, and
particularly working front end,
often you add weird code to make
things work in older browsers.
And having a decent
commit message
that explains what the change
was, but more importantly, why
you made it will really help
you and future developers
from removing that coding and
then breaking functionality
in older browsers.
OK.
[MOUSE SQUEAKING]